could you tell us your exact game day
routine so I could do that because like
I know at at 5 32 I do this at 5 38 I do
this yeah okay
yeah I mean I'll start from like
I get there I get there relatively early
on start days I get there around like 1
32 so I can eat lunch because I'm not
hungry on when I pitch so like I gotta
eat early and then uh normally their
lineup has come by then okay so I'll go
uh I've already done all the scouting
but I'll go make sure that there's no
guys that aren't playing that are
playing or something like that and once
I feel good about how I'm gonna get guys
out I'll uh the one thing that I've
always done is I throw this ball against
the wall yeah I I always do and
um is that just getting the fill yeah
okay yeah there's you can't just go out
there and rip a thousand curve balls a
day you know but to flip curveballs
against the wall one hop and cat like
you can do that all day so I'm
constantly doing that I do that a couple
times
um DD sliders like that yeah so I do it
all I do every pitch and uh so that yeah
I've always done that and then at five
o'clock we have a little meeting
um okay so from one to you're from one
four o'clock I take a nap all right four
o'clock yes I got my cleats on I'm on
the training table I'm lying down
everybody's tiptoeing yeah
okay so and then and then at five
o'clock you have your meeting a little
meeting that takes like
10 minutes max okay yeah and then I'll
go down the weight room and warm up
558 heat packs heat packs of 558 623 go
out on the field okay
6 40. play catch
at home finish before the anthem so 657
finished warming up and then 708 and go
out of fuel